Zachary s brown that's me beeps -
learning - and it'll be - hi data I can
bring this back up anybody else
I'll let folks take a couple pictures
[Music]
a cool house which over in my side
there we go alright so the title of this
tutorial is deep learning and modern
natural language processing my name is
Zachary Brown I'm a data scientist at SP
global market intelligence we're a
subdivision of SP global that standard &
poor's they do the indices and all of
that fun stuff I do not work for that
division I work for another division
that has a pretty sweet web product for
doing research into financials and
energy sectors and mining and all sorts
of different different types of things
so our data at market intelligence has
traditionally been sourced by having a
bunch of documents scraped from
different places and then having
analysts go in and and extract data and
annotate datasets so one of the benefits
of that is that we have tons of really
really awesome very granular Lee
annotated data sets that go back maybe
15 20 years and then the other thing
that's awesome about being a data
scientist there is that we have lots and
lots of opportunity to help to automate
some of those extraction pieces and from
my personal standpoint it's really
awesome because a lot of that data is
just semi-structured or unstructured
text so we get to play around with lots
and lots of text we don't always use
deep learning in fact I think a lot of
the models that we have in production
right now don't require deep learning
they're just simple classification
models where we're traditional
vectorization methods work pretty well
but we're starting to use it more and
more and I've been trying to learn about
it and yeah so I developed this talk on
it so an outline of what we're going to
talk about I'm just gonna start out by
introducing what a general natural
language processing problem structure
looks like and then I'll talk about text
classification problems and I'll
introduce the perceptron now who knows
what I mean when I say perceptron
hands up who is trained it all right who
has played around with pi torch before
few people all right cool
so I'm gonna go into the kind of
painstaking details of how you actually
train a deep learning model once for the
perceptron after that I'm not going to
talk about it anymore and my intention
with this talk is not to get down into
the optimization nitty-gritty details or
not worry too much about the math but
really try to focus on how can we
leverage this this thing that is deep
learning this this architectural
approach to to solving machine learning
problems and how can I just match that
up with with NLP problems that have
different shapes because different
depending on your test your NLP problems
will have very very different shapes so
after we talk about text classification
and specifically the perceptron then
I'll talk about vectorization and
classification with recurrent neural
networks and then we'll go on to talk
about sequential models both from apart
speech tagging example and a more
advanced sequence to sequence model so
before I get started does anybody have
any questions it is deep debt learning -
NLP - pie data my name is Zachary
Zachary yes Brown that's the github repo
name
yeah yeah so all of this stuff this this
is actually in the Jupiter notebook I'm
using a framework called rise that just
displays your cells as slides so this is
all like all of the stuff that I'm going
to go through is in in the repo
cool so on to NLP problems structure and
I apologize to folks that worked in NLP
because this may come off as a gross
oversimplification of problems in that
natural language processing space but
from a really really general standpoint
you might say that you can start out
with some sort of a document and you
want to perform some tasks on this
document and in traditional machine
learning you would do walk through this
long-winded thing of feature engineering
and there are a lot of ways to engineer
features from text there there are a lot
of traditional ways there are a lot of
like very very straightforward ways just
counting up the number of words but
there's some sort of a vector eight
vectorization step where we produce a
numerical representation of our text or
parts of our text and then we have some
tests after we run that vectorization
step where we optimize some machine
learning algorithm and then produce a
model and then the output of that model
when we run inference could be another
vector it could be a vector of
probabilities it could just be a single
a single element so something like
binary document classification we would
run a document through our vectorization
process that would produce an input
feature vector and then our task would
just print would output just a single
number so just a single scalar quantity
here and that might be the probability
that this thing is true or false
for multi-class document classification
everything up until that last step looks
exactly the same so you vectorize your
stuff you run it through run it through
your tests but in this case you're going
to maybe produce three different numbers
maybe this is a softmax distribution
over different class probabilities if we
start to get a little bit get a little
bit crazier let's say that we have a
sentence from within an individual
document we might vectorize that thing
and produce a vector for every token in
the sentence every every word in the
sentence and then we run that through a
test and we produce a vector of maybe a
class probability for each one of the
words in that sense
so these are all different shapes of of
machine learning problems and we're
going to talk about how we can tackle
these different types of problems shapes
which correspond to a whole bunch of
different different problem types that
you would have heard about like named
entity recognition part of speech
tagging sentiment analysis all of those
different things we're going to talk
about how they map onto these just
general shapes for data science so we're
gonna start out easy with a neural net
so we're gonna dip our toe in the water
with deep learning and just use a
perceptron binary classifier so it's
really really straightforward
not a lot of magic going on there and
then we're just we're just gonna use a
traditional vectorization approach so if
I say tf-idf - who understands what I
mean when I say tf-idf alright so I'll
explain a little bit about tf-idf as
well but that's what we're going to use
is a tf-idf vectorizer and this is just
it's basically just counting up the
words in a document and using using your
word counts as features alright so here
is our example of text classification
and the perceptron and before I get into
that I'm actually going to take this
hoodie up so if you'll bear with me for
a second but do you have any questions
Before we jump into that that is in the
in the notebooks folder okay there's one
called one underscore perceptron that's
that's this specific set so it looks
like this when you're just looking at
the notebook alright then it expands it
to cells when you when you run a ride
server okay
you didn't give us like what scale that
saw like how many rows
you actually have it so we have I
recently worked on a a table modeling
problem where we want to identify what
table types of particular table is in in
texting we already do this pretty well
we extract the data from these tables
pretty well but we need to be able to
identify what the table type is to be
able to extract it so for the bed I
think that I trained actually Paul this
is Paul Arabic over here he actually
trained this this table classification
model weren't we using like like a
couple like a million rows or something
like that yeah yeah yeah and that's
those are either those are individual
tables from documents so it depends on
what scale you're talking about if
you're talking about like actual like
stock date daily stock date or something
we have tons of that if you're there's
just lots and lots of different data
types that we have cool so let's dive in
whoops I jumped out of my presentation
too quickly so first we'll talk about
the perceptron and neural network
optimization and then we'll jump into
the example so this is a perceptron we
have these inputs represented by x1 x2
through xn these are just your your
vector inputs for for your model and
then we have these lines going to this
node right here and I'll get into that
in a second but these lines represent
weights in your model so in this case we
would have one line there one weight for
every input that we have in this model
and then we might have another weight
that represents bias and this this model
is really really similar to something
like logistic regression it produces the
same thing so we have these weights and
then we have this node right here which
just sums up whatever's coming in
through this line and then apply some
sort of a nonlinear function called an
activation function to that so here I
just have it represented by a simple
sigmoid and then that outputs our Y hat
our prediction for the model so what
does optimization for this thing
actually look like well the first thing
that we do is we take each one of our
inputs multiply them by the sorg way
skim that line and then we sum all of
them up and we might have another line
coming in here that's just a bias as
well another parameter that we're
learning and we apply our non-linearity
and then that gives us our prediction so
we do
that's called a forward pass where we
just take our data take all the current
values of our model and just run our
data forward it's tons of matrix
multiplication once you get more complex
neural nets then we calculate loss which
is we just define some sort of a loss
function that produces a scalar value
for each example that you have and you
input your prediction and input your the
true value in this I should say is for
supervised learning so we do have a true
value and then you calculate your
gradients and this is where a little bit
of calculus comes in so I'm not going to
go into the nitty-gritty of that but
basically you calculate the contribution
of each one of the weights in your model
to that loss that you saw so the loss
represents how wrong the model was on
that forward pass on that particular
data that particular data element and
then this is figuring out well how much
did each one of these weights contribute
to that thing being wrong and then what
we do is we update those weights so this
is using we use different algorithms
stochastic gradient descent as the the
biggie that got lots of things started
and we just have some some parameter
called the learning rate and we just
subtract off from the the current value
of the weight whatever this contribution
of that weight to the loss was so you
just do this a whole bunch of times go
forward through your network calculate
your loss and then you do what's called
back propagation so you propagate that
loss backwards through to your
parameters and then you update your
weights and this seems like a lot of
stuff here but the reason that I'm
showing this is because this is each one
of these steps right here as an actual
like lying in PI torch code and that's
one of the reasons why I was thinking of
maybe doing this tutorial in Kerris and
caris is really really straightforward
and that's where I do a lot of my
prototyping like if I just want to see
if something is a good fit for a deep
learning model I'll I'll pull out Karis
but pi torch i like because it's very
explicit about everything and it tends
to be very cutting edge and get lots of
research papers with existing code bases
up on github really quickly so it's nice
sorry go ahead
hi torch do you find it more useful for
an image and text data and it reflect
with just any machine learning data set
I mean when engineering resources yeah
you could you could apply it to you
could use neural networks for any sort
of data set that you want um I was I was
actually having having a conversation
earlier as to like what why would you
use a neural net if you can just use
something else that works well and I
would say you don't need to use a neural
matter to use something else that works
well neural Nets work really really well
when you can purpose build an
architecture for the problem that you're
trying to solve
so for images you can you can build
these convolution on their own that's
that yeah and I'm gonna go into detail
about I know can you hear any more
questions yep
pardon
because I like soso for the two reasons
that I just mentioned a minute ago
I like how explicit it is about
everything if you're doing if you miss
something PI torch just won't won't run
so you really have to understand what's
going on and I like having that level I
like having to have that level of
understanding to actually execute things
like the fact that you actually have to
define enough optimizer and
call that optimizer and backprop
yourself like all of those things just
appeal to me from from the standpoint of
really having like a bare-bones
understanding of what's going on and
like I said you tend to see a lot of I
mean not to say that you don't see
papers academic publication code bases
in tensorflow or in Karis or any of
these other other code bases as well but
it's I've noticed there are a lot of
them in torch so if we want to try out
some cutting-edge thing and I don't want
to code something up from scratch pi
torch there's almost always like a PI
torch repository a github repository
that hasn't implemented in bi torch
all right now we'll move on to a
perceptron example so I'll drop down to
the notebook and can you all see that
okay should I make the text a little bit
bigger is that okay can I get a thumbs
up come back
those hurt up side all right cool so the
first thing that we're gonna do is load
in and clean a dataset so we're using
the Stanford large movie review data set
so it is literally just a poops be my
imports
so this will take a second to clean it
up so it's just movie reviews and then
sentiment so was this a positive movie
review or a negative a movie review this
datasets nice because they chose
extremely polarized examples so
something that's that's negative tends
to have lots of words in it that are met
but have negative connotations and stuff
that's positive tends to have lots of
positive kind of tape words in it so all
I'm doing here is just cleaning up the
text a little bit so I'm using a list
comprehension to create convert it to
lowercase and then get rid of all my
punctuation characters so this isn't is
it super pretty there's much better
frameworks for doing this but this just
gets the job done and this is just a
minimal pre-processing so this is the
original you can see it has a comma in
it in a whole bunt and different cases
this is my cleans text and now I'm going
to use just a traditional vectorization
approach use a tf-idf vectorizer from
scikit-learn
to to count all the words in this data
and then create a vector out of that so
the vector for a new sentence that i
pass in is just the count of every word
that that that particular sentence has
in it and well that's that's actually a
count vectorizer what a tf-idf
vectorizer does is it takes your term
frequency which is your count and then
it divides by your inverse document
frequency so how many of our documents a
particular word occurs in it just
divides by that number so it has some
sense of your overall corpus from that
inverse document frequency but for the
most part you're just doing word
counting so here I just call tf-idf dot
Finch
text cleaned so I take my cleans text
and then I'm gonna print out the total
tokens in this input corpus just so we
can see with with this see how big data
is data
so this is 50,000 examples so with
50,000 movie reviews how how big is this
corpus going to be I'm going to limit it
to a thousand features so tf-idf
vectorizer has this thing called max
features I'm going to limit it to a
thousand so I don't have to have a like
super super huge neural net here and
then just fit and transform and then I'm
going to just do a little bit of
transformation on my labels as well and
then create a training and test set so
this will take just a second I tried
running this on the full the full corpus
that it'll spit out the size here in
just a second and my computer didn't
like me so yeah there's a hundred eighty
thousand distinct tokens in that and you
can do things like removing stop words
remove the remove and to reduce that a
bit but you would have naively a vector
of length one hundred eighty thousand to
feed into your model that might work
well for some machine learning models
and in fact some of the machine learning
models that we haven't in production
just use tf-idf vectorization to read
them into an SVM and they they work
really well but we're not going to do
that for this particular use case so now
we're going to dive into actually doing
our percept on perceptron and classifier
so here we have our features features of
0 this is just a vector of 1 by 1000 so
and then our labels of 0 is just a
single a single number and I have it I
have it wrapped in an array here just to
make make life a little bit easier so
now we're gonna use those things and to
make a perceptron we're going to use
something called a linear layer which is
just like the fundamental unit for
neural networks
it just takes inputs and and multiplies
them by some weights and then give you
gives you some outputs and this is
really just you can think of it as just
a matrix of weights that you're learning
in our case our matrix because our input
dimension is 1000 in this case and our
output dimension is 1 it's going to be a
matrix of shape 1000 by 1 so that's just
a vector so we're just learning a vector
way
I'm also setting bias equal to true here
to tell it to learn an extra an extra
bias wait then we want to squash that
down so I'm just going to define an
instance of the sigmoid function here
and all of these things are imported
from Torche dot and then if if anybody's
following along at home and then I'm
going to specify a loss function here
and we're going to use binary cross
entropy loss and that's a typical loss
function for for binary classification
problems and then we're just going to
use basic Stowe KD stochastic gradient
descent to optimize this and when I
initialize my optimizer here I have to
pass in the parameters that actually
want to initialize and the only
parameters our sigmoid doesn't have any
parameters our loss function doesn't
have any parameters so the only thing
that I'm going to pass in are the
parameters for my linear layer and I'll
just specify a learning rate of 0.001
because lots of tutorials do that and I
don't want to stand out from the crowd
so that was really anticlimactic so
there's not not much fun going on there
but now I have all these objects defined
now here's where it gets a little bit
fun one of the reasons that I really
like PI torch is that you can just you
don't have to have something all wrapped
up in a model you can just create a
linear layer create a vector that will
input to that linear layer and just pass
it through that and then look at the
output inspect it you can do all of this
stuff step by steps you really
understand what's going on so we're
gonna do that I'm just going to comment
out a whole bunch of rows in this
notebook just so everything doesn't
print out at once
so here I'm starting by just grabbing an
example of the features an example of
the labels and then I'm converting them
to tensors so I'm converting them both
to floating float tensors so this is
just the fundamental data type and
remember when I said that we have to do
a little bit of calculus Torche knows
how to do that calculus with respect to
these data types so that's that's one of
the cool things that it buys you and
then the shape of my feature tensor is
just one by a thousand so it's Torche
dot size instead of numpy size or a
numpy array dot size and cool now I'm
going to take that and I'm going to pass
it through my linear layer and I do that
by calling the dot forward method I
think what most modules dot forward is
is also implemented just as like a call
to the the actual layer itself so you
can just call linear with parentheses as
well but I like to explicitly calling
that forward and then I'll print what
the output of that should be what what
should the what's the shape of that
output what if you guys know what should
the shape of my linear layer output be
one one right because we're doing a
binary classification problem so yeah
it's just one by one so it's just it's a
one by one matrix which is just a single
value then we're going to take the
sigmoid of that guy and just print out
the output of that so we've squashed
whatever value was in there down between
zero and one and then we'll calculate
the loss so to calculate the loss I just
take my sigmoid output and I'm calling
that view on this and all this does is
just squash it down to just a single
dimension instead of having that
additional one dimension of one and then
I feed in whatever my X whatever my
predicted or my actual value is so now
we have our loss and you see this is
kind of interesting so there's this
thing that says grad function and this
tells Torche how to actually calculate
that gradient how to carry out the
calculus for this particular thing for
the sigmoid output you have the gradient
function is just sigmoid backwards so
it's the derivative implemented
implemented
americlean torch so this is the thing
that I think is really really cool
I can propagate this thing backwards by
calling law stop backward and this is
going to take take that loss and
calculate all the gradients of my
parameters so if i propagate that guy
backwards then I can check the weights
and biases and then I can up take a step
of my optimizer that's where I actually
update the weights and then I can print
out the weights and biases again this is
my bias tensor before this is my bias
gradient and now my bias tensor has been
updated so this is it's it's all there's
like no magic here it's literally just
like the only magic is that it really
does a good job of keeping track of
derivatives and there's something called
Auto bread and torch that does that
really well so now onto actually
training our neural map so we have all
of these feature vectors
the first thing I'm just going to loop
through all of my examples and I'm just
gonna have this thing called iterator
which keeps it keeps track of those I'm
gonna zero out my gradients at every
step because I don't want to just keep
accumulating gradients that are added to
my weights then I'm going to grab a
feature and Target I'm going to convert
them to float tensors run them through
my linear layer run them through my
sigmoid layer calculate my loss add it
to total loss so I can keep track of how
much actual loss I have here call
backwards and then take a step this is
all of these things are really really
common like boilerplate for any sort of
PI torch model that you see and that'll
run there's 37,000 training examples in
this little toy dataset and all right
it's done now how well did it do I can
take the same data or the same person
the same exact process and just run my
text data test data through it there's
one thing that you'll see later on where
I call something I call like linear eval
which converts any converts your layers
into an evaluation mode and that just
turns off things that are undesirable
during inference but a linear layer in
this exam
doesn't have any of those things so so
we don't have to worry about that we saw
so we see after training on our data set
we have an accuracy of 0.8 so that's not
very great so why is everybody
super-excited about it about deep
learning so two things this isn't the
perfect problem for deep learning we're
not using deep learning to vectorize our
data set and I've only run my data set
through my model once so for traditional
machine learning models or typical
machine learning models you usually just
train on your data once or maybe you do
some cross validate and try to try to
estimate the the performance of your
model on a holdout data set but you
typically just run your data through
once because we're doing stochastic
gradient descent we do just run our data
through multiple times and you you will
get to a point where you're not going to
get any more gains on there but you'll
see your metrics actually leveling out
so if you've ever looked into any sort
of deep learning blogs or anything and
seeing the term epic or epic you that's
just talking about the number of times
that you're running your your data
through your model so I actually have a
model implemented here so I can pull
that up in just a second but this is
what your actual training would look
like so this model that I have that I'm
going to define right here takes in what
the max features what the input shape of
my data is and just gives me this model
thing and now this model has a dot
forward method and that does all the
stuff that I was doing that runs it
through the linear layer and executes
the sigmoid I'm gonna specify my binary
cross-entropy
and I'm gonna run this for five epochs
now so we're doing all the same stuff
that I just did and we'll print out the
the accuracy for each one of these
and well that's running I'm not sure
because I'm a slow talker that we're
gonna have time for me to pause for
people to try it like blink around on
their keyboards and try out the examples
that I have but in this folder I have a
dash stub file for each one of these
notebooks and that the thing that I just
walked through where I defined each one
of the layers and then passed an example
a piece of data for each one of the
layers that spot is blank in all of
those notebooks so I explained how to do
it and then that's for you to actually
implement so I feel like hands on the
keyboard is a really really great way to
learn so I hope that somebody will take
advantage of that alright so this thing
finished
so our loss per epoch is decreasing
overall which is good and our validation
accuracy has gone up which is good as
well
so you're just optimizing the parameters
so you can just keep updating the
parameters on your just keep updating it
so so what you I'm feeding it through
one example at a time what you would
normally do is take I didn't want to get
get too deep into it but what you would
normally do for like you would normally
run mini-batch stochastic gradient
descent where you grab a random batch
from your data set and then run that
through and grab another random batch
and if you just keep running it through
your it's just a feature of deep
learning that your loss will keep keep
decreasing to some extent
so picture yourself it's like you have
this lost function space right and after
you run through you start out at some
randomized spot and then you explore by
moving running through the data set this
this loss feature space well now you're
here and when you saw the first example
you were up here before so now the first
example might node you a little bit more
in the right direction because you're in
a different space in a different part of
your loss feature space does that does
that make sense all right cool
what yeah yeah and and you can yes you
are scaling by a learning rate as well
which you can there's like stochastic
gradient descent is the the most naive
way to optimize this but there are a
bunch of other different optimization
algorithms that both modify your
learning rate and take into account past
steps as well so there's something
called like momentum and AD a grad and
atom there's a whole bunch of there's a
handful of different optimizers so here
we're going to just look really quickly
at a multi-class model and I'm just
gonna run through this quickly just to
show you the difference between a binary
output and multi-class output so here
we're just using Stack Overflow
questions and answers and I've just
pulled out labels eight different label
types run through the same exact stuff
that we did before and now we have a
linear layer but instead of having an
output size of 1 we have an output size
of our label size which is 8 so instead
of just outputting a single value the
output shape from this linear layer will
be of dimension 8 so 1 by 8 we can walk
through that same exercise again and
you'll see that oh I'm sorry it's not 8
it's 5 so you'll see that the the shape
from your linear output is just a 1 by 5
vector as well and your soft max output
shape is just going to be 1 by 5 as well
so here the only things that we have to
change to take this from a binary
classifier to a multi-class classifier
are to change the dimension the output
dimension of our linear layer and we
also want to change our
function so our arts sorry we want to
change our the clap the the squishing
function that we have here so we're
gonna use something called softmax which
is just the multi-dimensional like a
multi-dimensional version of the sigmoid
so we're going to use something called
log softmax here because log softmax
works with this negative log likelihood
loss function so these two you'll see
commonly together
I wanted to explicitly call out that
we're using a soft max on this layer
there's another another output a loss
function criteria that combines these
two together called cross-entropy loss
so that's just implementing cross
entropy there and then we can do the
same thing training this model and this
will take just a minute longer to Train
than the other one because there's a
little bit more data I think I have a
hundred thousand training examples here
and we can get pretty good accuracy on
this I think it's upward it's like
around a unit or something like that so
does anybody have any questions before
we move on to sequential models
everything in here totally
straightforward yeah if you if you guys
have any questions ask you can think of
a tensor as just being torches version
of an umpire right so like an umpire
you can have an array of floats and
umpires it's optimized for four
calculate for vector vector eyes
processing that's just torches version
of that and it has this additional
feature that torch is aware of how to
calculate the gradient of different
types of tensors with respect to their
inputs and outputs
what was my prediction video showing you
when you predict your actresses
the so what was the wire what was my so
my Y is just the whether or not somebody
it was a positive or negative yeah so in
in that sorry in the second example that
was yeah yeah there were five so it was
Stack Overflow questions and answers so
it was the question and then whether or
not the answer was tagged with Python
Java JavaScript or a couple of different
languages
yeah so after after a few epochs this
looks like it's getting up around 70%
overall accuracy on a five class data
set so for just training this for a
couple minutes it's not but it's not
doing anything really that we couldn't
do with just like an SVM or or any type
of other classifier so what can anybody
tell me what the thing that we neglected
with our naive vectorization there is
grammar in structure so things being
next to each other can mean things with
tf-idf vectorization you can take some
of that into account by using I just
used to you to Gramma's there so just
single words you can take diagrams
trigrams and that's cool that will work
if you have a really good feature
selection methodology then that can work
really really well but that can also
explode your feature space if you count
the number of individual words that's
one thing but then if you start counting
pairs of words then you have a lot more
features there yes and we'll we'll get
to that you're getting ahead of me
though
yeah yeah so that that's that's a great
great question so I didn't talk about
that at all I just had a single layer in
there but you can have a whole bunch of
linear layers just stacked on each other
and those are called hidden layers you
have your input layer and then you have
an in anything that's between your input
and output layer is called a hidden
layer and it's called a hidden layer
because it doesn't have it doesn't
directly interact with the input or
output and you can have I mean it's
really you can think of it it's just
introducing additional parameters into
your model so if you think that your
data is like really really really
complex and you want to capture a lot of
complex dependencies you could have like
ten layers in there it's gonna take
longer to Train and you need to at that
point balance the number of parameters
that you have in your model versus the
number of training example
that you have
all right so we didn't take into account
what I would call context of all of the
words that we fed into our naive
classifier there so how can we do that
recursive neural networks provide a way
for us to do that so they look at the
context around each thing that you're
turning into a vector and they allow you
to incorporate some of that into it so
here we'll talk about using recurrent
recurrent neural networks for encoding
for text classification we'll talk about
just recurrent neural networks in
general we'll touch briefly on word
embeddings and then we'll get into an
example cool so multi class document
classification is what we just did we
use tf-idf vectorization and then we
used a perceptron classifier here so now
we're going to use an RNN or recursive
neural net to vectorize here and then
we're still going to use a perceptron
classifier at the end we're still just
gonna use that same architecture of just
a linear layer feeding into and an
n-dimensional output where n is our
number of classes so that thing is gonna
stay pretty consistent through the rest
of this tutorial so what is a new
recurrent neural network have people
seen this diagram before it's all over
the internet if you go to like any blog
everybody's stealing this from I think
that this is the guy that created these
these visuals Christopher olla so I'm
going to credit him with these these
pretty visuals that I did not create but
this is a recurrent neural map it takes
some sort of input and in this case this
XT this is a vector and output some
output some H sub T and that's a vector
the the the letters here are a little
bit strange so this H stands for
hypothesis but that's just our output
vector so this in many ways just looks
like a single like linear layer or a
single perceptron where this black box
right here would be the perceptron so it
takes in an output takes in an input of
whatever shape that we have and outputs
vector of a different shape but then we
had this recurrent connection here so if
we unroll what this thing looks
it allows us to feed in a sequence of
things and have it learn have it bake
into the output for a particular time
step information about the input from
the previous time step so we can feed in
let's say each one of these vectors
represents a word or let's say each one
of these inputs is just a state like a
stock price at a particular day or
something you could feed those in and
then the recurrent neural network this
recurrent node here outputs what's
called the hidden state to the next to
do the computation of the output for the
next time step so one important thing to
note here is that this a is the same
across all of here
meaning that you're updating those
you're updating the same set of ways
these aren't a whole bunch of different
nodes this is one node with the same
internal weights that are getting
updated at every time step so the nice
thing about recurrent neural networks is
because there's this right arrow that
propagates information forward this way
if we have time or if we have sequential
data this time step the output at this
time step knows a little bit about the
input at this time step it has context
baked in and this is just a single
directional recurrent neural net so with
the arrows just going one way so it's
just baking in information from the
previous iterations of whatever sequence
that we're looking at but you can have
something called a bi-directional
neural bi-directional recurrent neural
net which just does this thing both ways
and then just like stacks the vectors on
top of each other if you want to bacon
contextual information from both sides
of whatever your particular output is so
a vanilla recurrent neural network just
takes your input and the hidden state
from the previous time step combines
them runs 10h activation function
traditionally on it and then outputs
your output and turn by outputs your
output to the next time step
well so this works pretty well for short
sequences it doesn't work particularly
well as your sequence length gets gets
really really big and that's because if
you remember back when I said that we're
doing a little bit of calculus here your
derivatives and the contribution to your
two-year loss from each one of those
successive derivatives they can either
get really really big or really really
small and kind of squash information
from really previous time steps so
vanilla recurrent neural networks don't
have a very long memory so they created
this thing called a long short-term
memory Network and I'm not going to get
into the the complicated awesomeness
that's going on here but two things to
know about these they retain their
memory better and func like from a
practical point of view they have two
input States here so you're gonna be
feeding in two vectors from a previous
time step so this one up at the top is
called the hidden state just like for
vanilla recurrent neural network this
one at the bottom is called a cell state
and these just contain different parts
of information that allow you to
propagate information for longer so for
a deeper dive into the necessity for and
the implementation of L STM's check out
that that blog where I pulled these
these images from because he does a
really really good job of doing a deep
dive into why this doesn't why it
doesn't work that well for vanilla
neural nets and why we need to use LS
TMS so because they work better for a
lot of longer slightly longer sequences
and we have slightly longer sequences
here I'm going to be using LST NS and
that just means that when I refer to
something as hidden it's really impact
on just a couple of vectors or a couple
of torch tensors one is our hidden state
and one is our cell state so that's the
biggest reason that I'm calling this out
here somebody have a question
so when you pass it it's actually a
Python couple of height or attention
tensors or is it a multi-dimensional
pipe or it's just yeah you can just pass
in an icon tupple you'll see that in the
code when I when I initialize those guys
so if we want to before with our with
our tf-idf vectorizer we just encoded a
whole sequence of words just text
naively to a single vector we can do the
same thing by using an LS TM if we just
ignore all of the hidden state there all
of outputs up until the last one because
it is if this recurrent neural network
has worked right then this should
contain contextual information from the
entire past so this is a way of encoding
a sequence of things into a single
vector but also having that single
vector be context aware of how the
things that contributed to it
interactive so like I said for sequence
classification this guy just outputs a
vector so we can just toss our
perceptron on the end of that and do our
actual sequence classification so an
example of that might be we feed in
words here and then we output if it's
positive or negative so simple sentiment
classification like like our first
problem was but what's what's the
problem with this diagram what what
haven't we talked about I said that the
inputs to this are vectors right and I
have I have words here so how do we how
do we feed a word into something that's
expecting or that there
we have to vectorize those somehow right
so a naive way would just be to use a
one Haughton coding strategy which is
what our what our account vectorizer is
essentially doing right it's just saying
that I have 500,000 words so the word
the is one and then four hundred four
hundred ninety nine thousand nine
hundred ninety nine zeroes right all
right so what about the inputs to BR mmm
so I could use I could use just this
naive diagonal representation where I
one huh encode all of our all of our
words that's still a really high
dimensional representation and I don't
want to have to do that so it would be
cool if I could get a dense
representation and it would be even
cooler if this dense representation knew
a little bit about the word so have you
guys heard of word Tyvek or glove and
betting's or word embeddings in general
there are a lot of ways to get dense
representations of words using
unsupervised machine learning approaches
I'm not going to get into that but
instead I'm just going to treat each one
of these words as just a vector of
weights and that's basically what word
Tyvek and glove and all of the work
Tyvek all the the neural based
approaches are doing so I'm just going
to initialize what I'm going to call an
embedding layer with just a set of
weights of dimension n for every single
one of my words and I'm going to let the
model learn a representation for that
word so the cool thing is if you train a
model on a classification task that's
really specific to like a
domain-specific corpus let's say you're
working in finance you can take if you
use one of these embedding layers to
learn weights for each one of the words
that's going into your model the the
embeddings that you've learned are going
to be really useful for other tasks as
well especially if it's really
domain-specific everybody likes to play
around with with glove and betting's and
in word Tyvek embeddings and all of
those other fun ones because they they
can give you a little bit of lift on
your naive model but from from a
practical standpoint if you're working
in a
cific domain if you're working in
healthcare or finance or anything like
that
and you train your own embeddings that's
going to give you a substantial lift
over one of these these publicly
available embeddings that could give you
substantial lift over the publicly
available embeddings that were trained
on something like Wikipedia sorry go
ahead
[Music]
categorical embedding so you mean like a
100 coating of categorical variables
yeah yeah so you could I mean we're
essentially treating this if we were to
flip this towards like a categorical
lens we're essentially just treating all
of our words as different categories
right and just learning a factor for
each one of those so if you have like I
don't know a handful of categories you
could just create an embedding layer for
those and learn and betting's for your
categories as well and feed those in as
a separate input to your neuron that so
I I haven't I haven't done that but
there's a guy on my team that keeps
talking about it so I feel like there's
a chance that I will at some point yep
so cool so we are going to just let our
model we're gonna feed inwards and each
one of these words is gonna have a
vector of weights associated with it and
we're just going to let our model learn
what those weights are so let's jump
into our LS TM text encoding example so
again I have all of these fun inputs or
all of these fun imports and I'm going
to do the same exact text cleaning that
I did before and what we're using here
is the r8 dataset so this is from
Reuters and this is just an annotate I
think that's from the 80s or something
but it's just an ant a hand annotated
data set of topic content and I think
that there's eight different labels that
we have here so it's a whole bunch of
news articles and then a hand annotated
label of like this is about earnings and
this is about acquisitions or something
like that so we can say data label and
unique yes there's this is the use case
where we have 8 different output labels
so what am i doing here oh yeah so when
we create this embedding layer what we
want to do is figure out how big so the
embedding layer is essentially just a
dictionary lookup between a word and a
vector of weights for that word and our
pipe torch just uses that and optimizes
those those weights just like we were
doing for other things but what we need
to do too
to initialize that embedding layer it
the the embedding layer doesn't like an
actual text string as its input so first
you have to integer encode all of your
words so you have to figure out how many
words you have an integer encode all of
your words and then the embedding layer
will just expect a sequence of integers
or just a single integer and it will
convert that into a vector for you so
all I'm doing here is just splitting the
text up figuring out how many words I
have for it and then calling that my
vocab size figuring out how many labels
I have for it and calling that my label
size and then I'm creating two different
dictionaries here and there are just to
be clear there are a lot of this is like
kind of hacky code I would say this is
just stuff that I put together to
illustrate the point and show you how
you would do it by hand
Torche actually has a lot of utility and
convenience functions that will do all
of this stuff for you
but it's just like one call on an entire
text text data set and I wanted to
explicitly show what what Beth is doing
under the hood so we create a dictionary
that's word to index so that just
translates so a word to an integer
encoded index and then index toured so
we can get back same thing for labels
and then we have a text encoded and a
label encoded column to our data frame
pulling the values out of the label
encoded and pulling the features out of
the text encoded so our after I do that
that should run quickly our labels
are just single integers for a single
training example and I can do like
labels : tens you can see it's just a
whole lot of individual labels and then
features of zero these are the integer
encoding of the actual words in that
sentence so I just split them up on
whitespace and coded each one is an
integer and then this is what we're
gonna feed into our embedding there so
it's going to take this integer 19,000
253 and instead of having to have a
vector of length 19,000 I can say well I
want to represent this word in a vector
of length 100 of floating-point notice
then I have a hundred floating-point
numbers instead of this one out encoded
gross Ness so now let's start putting
the pieces of the the actual model
together so this is our embedding layer
you just have to specify the number of
embeddings so it knows how much memory
to allocate and your embedding dimension
so I want to take each one of those
words and have have a representation of
that word of dimension 100 love and word
Tyvek I think have have open data sets
that are dimension like 100 and 300 and
maybe even 50 as well so 100 is a nice
round number then I'm going to take an
LST m layer so this is that long
short-term memory and all we have to do
is specify the input size that's the
length of our input vector that's coming
up from the bottom and that should be
the same as our hidden dimension because
I've encoded the words as these hunger
dimensional vectors and then I'm going
to pass that up into my LST m and then I
can separately specify the hidden size
and that's going to be the length of
this vector that's being passed over to
the right so any questions on that and
that's also I'm sorry going to be the
length of the the output size vector as
well
so I create an LS TM layer and then this
is where you were asking if it's just a
Python couple so I'm going to initialize
my my hidden layer my hidden layer and
my context vector or my hidden vector
and my context vector to just zero so I
do that it's just like numpy that zero
is just torched zeros and I want it to
be of shape one 150 and this is that
this middle dimension right here is my
batch size and for all of the stuff that
I'm doing here I'm not doing any like
any batching of my data usually to run
torch in best practice and to be memory
efficient and have things actually run
quickly you want to batch your data so
send through 50 examples at once for the
sake of this tutorial I'm not doing that
because then you have to worry about
making sure that all your sequences are
the same length and you have to do
things like padding and that just goes
down and Grocery that hole there's again
convenience functions to handle all of
that but I would feel like I would be
doing you guys a disservice to just use
convenience functions all over the place
so here I normalize or I initialize my
hidden state and my contents there my
cell state to zeros and then I just
called that tupple lsdm so that's my
hidden state and then for my perceptron
I have this linear layer that's going to
take the output dimension from my LST m
so this thing up here is going to be a 1
by 50 vector and reshape that into my
label size so this is just a matrix that
is going to do matrix multiplication on
that vector and output something of the
dimension of my label size and then I'm
going to again use my log softmax and my
negative like log likelihood loss on
this my log softmax I actually have to
specify a dimension here so I'm
specifying dimension equals 1 so it
calculates along the right dimension and
then we're good to go
so here what again we'll walk through
each one of those steps just sending a
single example through to make sure that
we know what we're doing we know what's
going on here so and I'm not going to
walk through the optimization part here
but my integer feature sequence shape is
62 and then my integer target shape is 1
so this means that I have a
one-dimensional vector for my output
that's just the label the integer
encoding integer encoding of the label
and then for my input sequence I have a
sequence that's 62 words long for this
first example so now I'm going to pass
that through the embedding layer and
what what should the shape of this be I
pass a sequence of 62 through my
embedding layer we all get to drink beer
really soon I promise
there's beer upstairs it's so my
embedding layer is of dimension 100 so
I'm gonna pass each one of these
integers through and it's just going to
convert that into a sequence of 100
dimensional vectors
so it's going to be 62 by a hundred
instead of just 62 now so now I have a
vector of a sequence of 100 dimensional
vectors and now I can feed that sequence
into my LST m and that's going to
produce two different outputs so I are
actually one thing I need to call
because LST MS don't so all the other
layers have an option to not work in
batch mode LST MS required that you have
this additional batch dimension so I'm
gonna call this stop on the squeeze
method on the first dimension to
basically just like if I have a two
dimensional vector I'm just going to add
another dimension in the middle so the
shape of this guy is going to be
whatever the shape of this guy was
whatever the first dimension of this
then one and then the second dimension
of this so I'm just adding an additional
batch dimension in there and then we
will pass that guy through the LST M so
now we have our LST M output is a vector
of 62 by our batch size by 50 so for
every single input that we had in that
sequence you remember in our unrolled
LST M diagram we had an output at the
top for every single one of those we're
sequence classification we don't need to
use all of those outputs we could we
could we could take those and try to
come up with some fancy way of like
maybe smashing them down into a single
vector and then feeding those into our
perceptron but that last hit that last
output state should have most of that
contextual information encoded in it so
we'll just take the last output state so
here we're going to retain only the
final output State and this should just
be a 1 by 50 vector so now we can feed
that into our perceptron we've encoded
that entire sequence into a vector of
size 50 and now we can just feed that
into a normal linear layer and output
with with an output dimension of
whatever our class number of classes is
and that that should work I hope that'll
work
so we've run that through our final
linear layer and then we run it through
our soft Max and then we can calculate
our loss so I'll run all of these guys
together so we have a loss value of one
point eighty and that doesn't mean
anything to me right now because we
haven't left this train so I don't know
what that's in a relationship but we see
that our linear output outputs a 1 by 8
our soft max output again outputs a 1 by
8 because that's just applying a
function element-wise to that and then
our target shape is just it's just a
single integer so when we input our loss
we are one input to our loss this should
be a sequence of integers and then this
should be a sequence that this should be
the this should have one element for
every single class that you have because
it's the probability for each one of
those classes so again I just wrapped
all of that stuff and up into a module
and if anybody wants me to dive into
what the actual like model the
boilerplate and everything for the model
looks like I'm happy to do that maybe
right after I run through this section
so we can get a peek at that but I
defined an RNN classifier model which
just executes all of those steps in a
method called forward so all it's doing
is on an it it's defining all of those
things that I did in that first cell
which is your linear layer your LST M
layer your embedding layer and then
calling all of those things in the same
sequence that I just did on forward so
I'm specifying an optimizer and my loss
function here here I'm going to run it
for 10 bucks
calling model dot train although I don't
think I need to looping through all of
the data and then zeroing out my
gradient doing all of those things that
we did before for the sake of time I'm
just gonna run this on the first 32
elements of the sequence I a lot of
times in practice will do this just to
make sure that my model is actually
running because otherwise it's kind of a
pain in the butt if like it if you're
feeding in these long sequences and then
something blows up on like the the
second epoch or something it's
so we'll run this guy and well this is
running I can actually open up to see
what this are any classifier model looks
like if anybody's interested is anybody
interested or I can keep sublime text
closed yeah all right I got one nod so
that's enough for me
modules
[Music]
all right so I have all my same inputs
here and then with any sort of PI torch
model all of this stuff is just like
your basic boilerplate so you'll have an
init method which which calls the the
initialization of its superclass and
then you just define like all of this is
just just boilerplate the super init but
this specifies like your model
parameters so in this case I had a
hidden dim size and imbedding dim sized
boat capsized all of this stuff and then
I just initialize all of those different
layer types that I have so I have my
embedding layer my LST M my linear
specify my batch size on that I have my
log softmax and then I have this thing
called an it hidden which just does that
it just creates the first element of my
hidden state my cell state and then your
forward pass so this is just running in
a particular value of your input through
all of those layers so your initializer
and your forward pass are the two things
that are required for all of your PI
torch models so the first time one of
one of the guys on my team recommended
that I check out PI torch like I looked
at the tutorial and saw that I had to do
all of this to do pretty much anything
and then I promptly closed that notebook
and imported here is an another one so
it's it seems like a lot of overhead but
like once you just get used to see like
once you write this out like a couple
times it's just like oh yeah then I you
you either just like automatically type
it out from muscle memory or you just
copy copy and paste from some other
notebook that you have go ahead
I have not yet I am really excited to go
I haven't had a use case since the last
use case that I had for it I started
developing right before fast day I did
there did there like main release and I
think there I'm like one point there on
some official release now and right
before I did that I started developing
and then I wasn't going to just like
switch code bases but I'm waiting for
another use case to use it it's supposed
to be awesome and I mean it has a lot of
a lot of stuff that's really close to
like really close to the heartbeat of
academic research there's lots of really
really like state-of-the-art models in
there so just for everybody not familiar
fast AI is a company that has a really
awesome deep learning package that does
a lot of this stuff for you it has a lot
of pre pre trainer pre-configured
architectures for handling these types
of problems and it's all written in
Python under the hood so there's lots of
lots of cool stuff there so I'll go back
to the notebook and this guy is training
so our losses at point nine seven and
our accuracy is at point seven four so
in the interest of time we have about
about twenty five more minutes I think
I'll move on to the next the next
section oh yeah so this is this is going
up I was gonna I just wanted to wait to
so you guys believe me that I'm actually
increasing the accuracy as I let this
thing trade so do we have any more
questions here before I move on to
actually doing some sequence to sequence
type things
sublime yeah you just so you just have
to create assembling and I don't know if
you go on if you every single time I get
a new computer I just Google sublime
text command line and there's some
tutorial or there's some blog post from
like 2011 or something that just tells
you where the default location that it
installs that is well yeah you it's just
not on your path by default
the word embeddings I used the entire
yet that's a good question so if you
don't do that then so the way to get
around that is to introduce an unknown
token and because otherwise you'll go
you'll go to pass through your test
example and you just won't have that in
there and it'll it'll fail so you can
pass through an unknown token that it
just returns if it doesn't have that
particular but that is a good point yeah
you could potentially have some data
leakage there if you do if you do that
if you're using embeddings trains from
somewhere else than you have to worry
about cool any other questions these
guys so these are the the hidden states
for the for the LST M so this is the
hidden the hidden state vector and this
is the cell state vector oh yeah you
don't
so torch previous versions of torch
prior to the one dot over these which
just happened I don't know like a month
or two ago prior to that torch didn't
have the ability to automatically know
how to differentiate a tensor with
respect to its inputs and outputs so you
had to wrap it in this torch Otto grant
variable Otto granted the package that
does the automatic differentiation and
it knew how to differentiate variables
so you just saw this everywhere in the
code and it was kind of annoying and I
just I copied and pasted some code that
I had from before the release over here
I just miss running this
in this network I have a single linear
layer which you can consider like a
hidden layer in the network so actually
it's probably better if I go back to
this diagram so you can think of this
being a hidden layer that has a complex
this has a hidden state which is a
vector a cell state which is a vector
and then a whole bunch of weights that
are the the hidden layer for this LS TM
so this would have a whole bunch of
weights that would be hidden layer
weights I guess and then your your
perceptron and out portion of this would
have a whole bunch of hidden hidden
layer weights as well yeah yes you can
just you can stack this thing on top of
itself and just create a whole bunch of
a whole bunch of that's a really good
[Music]
to two or three different layers we find
the different semantics
yes Oh Elmo is a new type of word
betting approach that it finds multiple
representations that are good for
different tasks all by just training
different layers and like the top layer
might be representative of like
contextual information or semantic
information the the bottom layer might
be much more like lower lower level this
is this is running on my laptop so I'm
not using any GPU acceleration here if
you do that you're gonna have a bad time
you're gonna be waiting for a long time
like I'm using it took me a while to
find these data sets that I have listed
here and some of them I even down
sampled so these are these are all the
data sets that I that I used for the for
this tutorial I also have a directory in
the notebooks directory called like data
set prep or something that shows you how
like I got them and it gives you
traceability into how I how I process
them and yeah some of them I had down
sample like this which one the stack
overflow Q&A is like billions and
billions of rows so that would be super
fun to like pop onto a GPU machine and
train a really really big neuron that on
but I it's not a good idea that on your
laptop they'll take a while and it'll
make if I mean you can probably hear the
fan on my laptop and that's just yeah
it's just not fairly small
but as is it all set up in your lap talk
to you that you use it immediately I
don't have a GPU I don't have an NVIDIA
GPU in this guy
I've looked into so yeah yeah so Apple
this this is a whole whole different
discussion but yeah so if I wanted to do
this I would just get an Nvidia an
external NVIDIA GPU because it's it's
just so tightly integrated with the CUDA
library and I try to get that yeah try
that yeah jumpin I mean so Amazon has a
really awesome deep learning ami deep
learning image and you can just like if
I want to do anything heavy-duty I'll
just it takes it takes like five minutes
to spin one up on one of Amazon's
heavy-duty GPU instances actually I
would highly recommend if you wanted to
play around with this ya get an AWS
account it's I think ninety cents an
hour for a p2 instance which is pretty
beefy to do like any of like a step up
from what I'm doing here and like I
don't know for what five ten bucks you
can play around with it for an entire
day and then just tear it down like it's
it's totally worth it if you want to get
into it the only thing that I'm not
doing here
is explicitly calling explicitly sending
the data to the GPU so there's you would
if I were to change my code to make it
function on a GPU there would be a whole
bunch of checks to see if a GPU is
available and there's a torch method for
that and then if the GPU is available
you would just call CUDA on all of your
tensors and that just sends it to the
GPU and then it puts the processing
there you don't want to do that if
you're just running in serial like I am
just running single examples through
because then you're just going to be
copying and pasting back and forth
you're just copying back and forth
between the GPU all the time but it
really helps out once you start having
batches of lots of data so you send a
whole bunch of data over the GPU it does
the calculation really quickly a minute
there
yeah and actually one of one of the
presenters for one of the presenters
tomorrow that's doing the authorial I
think his name is Robert Alvarez he's
doing an introduction the PI torch I saw
him give one previously and they he did
it using Google's collab and they will
let you run things on GPUs for free if
you run it in their in their notebook
and you connect when he did this
tutorial they actually had a TPU option
there too which is like wow so yeah if
you if you want to play around with this
stuff and not have to spin up in am i in
AWS that would be a good option as well
cool so this thing is making my laptop
slow now but yeah so got up to like 90
percent accuracy this data said I looked
at like benchmarks on it and like 98%
accuracy is like pretty standard there
pretty like like state-of-the-art
accuracy on this guy so this pretty sure
would eventually get up there if I let
it run for a little while but I'm gonna
kill this and then move on to the I sort
of got the stance or part of speech
tagging so the part of speech tagging
section of this so we up until now just
been talking about classification so we
have this like sequence of text we have
a document we have whatever we want to
be able to just output a single value
but what if we want to output a sequence
there's there's a whole bunch of
different use cases for this so we have
we do some vectorization and that
produces vectors of our words or
something and then let's say we just
wanted to output a single single value
for each one of those words what's a
good example use case or something like
that like what's a real-world use case
yeah yeah so part of speech I guess I
gave it away that's a stupid question I
gave it away with the name of the
notebook but things like named entity
recognition there's a whole bunch of
different tasks that you can do here
sentiment analysis of individual words
you could do there's lots of different
things so part of speech tagging named
at any recognition you can also do
extract of summarization so think of a
summarization model where you're feeding
it you feed in a paragraph of text and
you just want to figure out what words
you can chop out to produce a good
summary of that text if you have like
like news articles and headlines you can
play around with modeling that and see
if you can just chop out particular
words and produce a summary of that so
and that would just be like a binary
output on each one of the words that you
have saying yes I want to keep this or
no I want to throw this away so there's
lots of different use cases for this and
we're gonna focus on part of speech
tagging for what
probably so you couldn't use this type
of model but there are model if you if
you want to look into something like
that look up abstract and summarization
so abstractive summarization is a type
of sequence to sequence model that will
it's it has some similarities to the
last type of model that we're going to
look at and that can produce instead of
extractive where you're just chopping
words out abstract a summarization can
output words that weren't actually in
the initial document so if you train the
model that was specifically on like a
theme of a particular portion of text
you could probably get something working
that that's a really interesting use
case though yeah all right cool so and
any more questions before we hop into
I don't know I don't know off the top of
my head I would say if you want to
identify particular terms in in an input
sequence that are important to a
particular output does that make sense
so like you you know that something is
broken so there's a lot of non deep
learning approaches that would probably
work for that just like like simple like
text statistics over like a large a
large body of but if you wanted to have
a deep learning model you could use
something like we're gonna talk about
like a similar to a part of speech
tagger except just have your output for
each token in your sequence just be yes
or no this was problematic that the
issue with that is you would have to
have an annotated data set that has for
every single word in this review this
was problematic this wasn't this wasn't
this wasn't this was problematic and you
could you could do that you could
generate that by just like having some
interface lets you highlight the
problematic parts and just storing that
off right but you you'd have to get at
that type of data set before you can
develop something like and there are
tools for creating data sets like that
we we use some of them internally there
are open source tools I think is no it
used to be oh did it use the open source
all right I thought they so there's a
tool called prodigy I'll give give a
shout-out to explosion AI there's
there's a company that develops a an
open-source toolkit called Spacey which
is really really awesome for text
processing they also have a pay tool
called prodigy which lets you do that
type of annotation and it's a really
cool tool it does that job pretty well
[Music]
[Music]
yeah so we if I were to deploy a torch
model right now I would we have a
framework that will set up flask apps
for us like software is a service that
we use that will take like a function
and deploy that as as a flask app and do
all the wrapping and stuff from the
serving for you so that's how I would do
it but yeah there are a lot of
frameworks and I'm actually interested
to see where where PI torch goes with
stuff like that because to your point
what tensorflow was already like
thinking about that
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I mean at the end of the day all
your model is is the model architecture
so like the components that you have and
then individual weights you can even
like just take weights from a model that
you've developed in PI torch and just
export them to the same exact
architecture and the different different
framework as well so and there's there's
lots of like active research into doing
that for different platforms like like
if you train something on your computer
how do you get that onto mobile etc so
like yeah we just we use good old
plastic because plastic is cool so back
to the talk so before we were encoding a
sequence to a single vector and now we
want to encode a sequence to a sequence
of vectors and if you if I go back a few
slides I had a limit on the sequence to
sequence discussion that I started where
the input sequence is the same length as
the output sequence so you can if you
just use a single LST M that's that's
that's a constraint that you have now
that you you could model it if you're
like chopping words out doing extractive
summarization your output sequence could
be shorter than your input sequence
because you're explicitly saying I want
to chop out these words but this would
be for modeling a sequence where you
have an output from your model for every
input of your C ones so if we want to
implement part of speech tagging we have
our good old perceptron up here so we
just send in different words and we're
probably gonna use word vectors again
because they're they're cool and that's
what the cool kids do we send this up
through our LS TM it outputs something
and we run a perceptron classification
on it and it says this is an ever this
is an educated this is an educated and
the difference here is we no longer just
have for every batch that we send
through or every single example that we
send through we're not just going to be
calculating the loss on a single example
or a single vector with respect to the
target we're going to be calculating the
loss on multiple examples
with respect to the target so each one
of these guys is going to be a vector of
probabilities and each one of our
targets is just going to be an integer
so we're going to have if we just pass
one sentence through we're going to be
computing the loss for an example that
is the length of that a number of
examples that is the length of that
sentence
Oh for those yes so the loss function
typically has a way to it typically has
an input parameter that tells you what
you want to do there you can return all
of the individual losses if you want or
you can sum them or average those are
the the typical typical ways to do it I
think that the default is averaging and
it's usually done instead of so if you
take this picture and kind of tip it on
its side it's really just treating all
of those as a batch like in with with
mini-batch stochastic gradient descent
you're sending batches through anyways
so torches really has really robust
methods to deal with that and to take
care of that but we're just sending
through single examples at a time
because I don't want to deal with like
four-dimensional tensors and it's that
yeah it's beyond the scope of this
particular talk so any more questions
before we dive into more code can you
guys see this okay see the code okay
should I make it make it bigger good
yeah I don't think anything should be
cut off I try to stick to the the Pepe
Tanner did not have super super long
long comments so here we're going to
pull in a dataset called the the penn
treebank part of speech corpus so this
is actually included with NL TK and if
you go into the the data the data
acquisition notebooks that I have you'll
see where I just import an l TK and
literally just pull this thing out and
what this is is it's two parallel
sequences so the first one is just a
list of all the words from from sentence
the second one is just all of the part
of speech tags for that and I think that
it includes multiple languages or at the
very least includes different part of
speech tagging nomenclatures if you will
so different things that they call
different parts of speech and I think
that there's like eight year a hundred
different variations you know across
across the board and I've boiled it down
to just 12 so there's a way that you
there's like a method in NL TK that lets
you just boil this down to just 12 parts
of speech so we have this input sentence
and we have noun noun any punctuation is
actually separated off by so in the
tokenization punctuation is its own
token as well and that's learned as well
so there the punctuation label is just a
period
so again I'm going to figure out how
many words there are and create a word
to index and label two index vectors or
I'm sorry lookups and then just
calculate my my vocab size so a lot of
this is going to look almost exactly
like the previous example until we get
down so actually all of this is going to
look exactly like that nothing's nothing
has changed here except for the label
size label size is different here
but what is going to change is as we're
passing through this or actually can
anybody tell me what's going to change
when we do our forward pass here I think
that there's only like one line that I
haven't changed for this from the
previous example I shouldn't tell you
how how little I prefer so before when
we took the tensor that was the output
from our LS TM this is sequence length
times hidden layer size right because we
have a hidden we have an output for
every element in the sequence and for
classification we just took the last
element of that sequence we just wanted
a single vector to represent that whole
sequence so I went before I fed that
into our linear layer right here I had
final output of minus one I just took
the last element of that of that
sequence of my LS TM output but now
they're right here I had final output as
lsdm output of minus one here we're
gonna keep the whole that whole series
of outputs because we want to classify
each one of those things that each one
of those vectors that was output so I'll
just run this whole cell so I'll just
walk through really quickly so first we
convert to tensors run them through our
embedding so this produces vectors of
length 100 I think then we're going to
unscrew that to pop our batch size of
one into the middle of that tensor then
we're going to we already initialized
our first hidden state so this is that
tupple that has the hidden vector hidden
vector in the context vector and we're
gonna pass through our embedded sequence
and we have the hidden state output
which is the last hidden state from the
LST M and we have our lsdm output which
has an a vector output for every element
in our sequence I just put this in there
because this is where I took off the
minus one from before and then we are
going to pass
through our linear layer take the
softmax of that guy
and this is the softmax over all of our
whatever dimension our classes are
because we want to over all of our
classes convert that into a probability
so we don't want to take that over our
sequence lengths you have to be careful
what you calculate the softmax over this
gave me a bit of a headache a couple
nights ago so yeah just just be careful
with when you define your softmax here I
specified that I want to use dim equals
two so along the third axis and then I
calculate the loss so you can see I
start out with my featured shape my
future sequence shape is 18 my target
shape is 18 this guy is 18 by a hundred
which is what I expect I have 18 words
in this sequence and I have hundred
lengths the vectors after I pass it
through my LS TM now I have a vector I
have a sequence still of length 18 and I
have vectors of length fit so those are
my output vectors and now I want to use
those to classify each one of those
things so I have 12 different output
classes so after I've run it through my
linear layer this is just a matrix
transformation with whatever weights are
stored in that linear layer still give
me an output of length 18 my sequence
length is still 18 but my output vector
is now the right dimensionality the same
dimensionality as my number of classes
then I run my softmax on that which
should not do anything to the shape
right because it's just a transformation
can normalize and then I actually
squeeze that guy so I take out that
middle dimension here so unscrews
inserts a dimension squeeze takes that
dimension out and I do that because the
loss function is only expecting at this
dimension so I'm treating I'm
essentially treating this guy as my
batch size like I said before and then
that's my loss so now this part of
speech tagger looks almost identical to
the same model that I showed you guys a
few minutes ago so I won't open up
sublime again
then we can let this train for a minute
so well this is training I actually want
to let this train for I think five
epochs so do you guys have any questions
on part of speech tagging or sequence to
sequence models where the sequences are
the same length
no you guys stoked about a torch now so
I would not to toot my own horn but I
would recommend these notebooks because
they're like all the spots that I
haven't filled out are like the
necessary steps that you're going to
have to walk through in any tutorial
anyways and then the pipe torch website
has awesome awesome material they have
really really good examples
yeah yes oh I'm so the sequence length
is just whatever the sequence length is
for that particular input that you're
feeding it so that's the cool thing
you're feeding in this this variable
length thing and you're creating a fixed
length representation of that so for
yeah yeah so if you run if you run an
LST M on the entire text of a document
you're also going to have a bad done you
don't want to that's it's it's gonna
Ellis teams are notorious for being slow
to Train so there are there are other
ways to like you can run a convolutional
neural net over the work vectors and
that would be affect something that's
slightly faster you can also there's
there's something that's relatively new
called an intention mechanism which you
can use in lieu of using an LS TM with
just the word vectors as well those tend
to train a little bit faster or you can
just chunk up your document so we've
done we've done things where we just
take our whole even even like a
paragraph in some cases is too long
right so you just chunk that either you
use a sentence Iser to just chunk that
into sentences and then each sentence is
your input or you could just like
randomly chunk like take take random sub
sequences of that paragraph to train but
you don't want to have your sequence
length be over
I don't know maybe like 30 or 40 I don't
know if you have a deepening or like a
GPU cluster or something that you really
want to like make the fans run on really
hot then then you can run a ton of data
through it
yeah yeah yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't do
too much more than I don't know like
like sentences are like a short short
ish paragraph Turin LS TM I tried I
tried the middle of last year and I had
a bad time so I would not recommend it
let's see yeah so this guy is learning
I'll let it finish I think there's five
epochs here now I have ten I'll let that
guy keep running while I run through the
last section so before I start this it
looks like we're going to run out of
time so I'm happy to stay around and
finish this section or I'll just try to
run through it relatively quickly but
now we're gonna talk about might have to
zoom out here a little bit now we're
gonna talk about see point like actual
sequence to sequence model so if you
talk to a deep learning practitioner
they wouldn't call what I just described
to you sequence the sequence modeling
because it had the limitation that the
input sequence was the same length as
the output sequence and in terms of your
actual like targets so your target
length had to be the same length as your
your input length so a true sequence the
sequence model doesn't have that
constraint so it uses something called
an encoder decoder architecture and this
is really useful in things like neural
machine translation and a model not
terribly more crazy than the model that
I'm going to show you was I think the
first iteration of Google's Google
Translate I've engine so it's not like
these things work really well if you
throw a ton of data at them this is the
only example where it's not going I'm
not gonna let this thing train and show
you guys any results or anything because
I they take a long long time to train
with a ton of data so like on the order
of like weeks with large GPU machine
in huge corporate data so if we have
variable length sequence to sequence so
the length of our input is not equal to
the length of our output we can't just
use the outputs from our LS TM because
we don't know what the length of the
output should actually be we can't add
outputs to that thing so we have to
figure out another approach and the
easiest thing to do is just come up with
some sort of an encoder that encode
encodes a sequence and then have a
decoder that takes the encoding of that
sequence and decodes it into another
sequence so LS TMS are good for
sequences or recurrent neural nets in
general so we could probably use a
couple of those so the the basic
architecture looks something like this
we have our encoder here the quick brown
something-something fence and we have
the output in Spanish here and we just
have an encoder that encodes it into a
fixed length representation that we hope
captures all of the information from
this encode this input sequence and then
we feed that context into our decoder
and that produces a sentence so this
seems like but pretty cool we give this
to work there's a lot of really really
minor details that make this a little
bit challenging to implement they're not
really hard but it's just stuff that you
that you wouldn't really think of for
example how do you know when your output
sequences is done like how do you know
when you're at the end of the sequence
because this thing that's generating the
text if it's just figuring out what the
next word should be it could just go and
do that forever so the underlying
architecture for that is just to LSTs
so you have your encoder LS TM and all
you do is pass through your input
sequence through the entire LS TM and
then just grab the the last grab the
output state like we were doing for a
simple classification model so you just
grab your your final this final output
from here or actually we're gonna grab
the hidden state from down here so that
should encode the same thing except it
has the SEL state with it as well and
then we are going to initialize a second
LS TM
our decoder LST em with this context
vector so up until now I've been taking
I've been initializing the hidden state
in the cell state for all of our LS TM s
with just zeros so I've just been saying
I don't know anything about what this
should be so I'm just going to
initialize that with zero here we're
saying I'm going to initialize it with
all the information that I had from my
encoder all the information that the
fixed length representation that I had
from my input sequence I'm going to feed
that in and see my output sequence
generator with that and then again we
just have our perceptron classifiers up
here except up here instead of
classifying just like a small number of
classes this is actually going to be a
really really high dimensional
perceptron
excuse me classifier this is going to
have one output dimension for every word
that's in your output corpus so if
you're translating from English to
Spanish this is going to be a very very
long vector of Spanish words it's going
to contain a probability for being each
one of these words in your second in
your second language so sorry just sorry
to context switch but this guy finished
and I just wanted to show one kind of
cool feature of this
it's not working now never mind yeah so
so this this is working so when I
trained this before so when I first saw
this this is just running a sample
sentence through I went for a run today
so here run should be a noun right when
I fed it there's a little bit of
ambiguity here but when I ran this
sentence through before run was a verb
so it shows that it's not just creating
and it's not just learning a one-to-one
mapping it's actually learning
contextual clues
this isn't proving my point but I
promise you it did it did earlier today
so so yeah but it is at least learning
some some sort of part of speech tagging
here so back to our encoder decoder
architecture so we have an encoder which
is an LS TM grab the final hidden state
feed it in initialize our decoder LS t
em with that hidden state and then have
a very high dimensional perceptron
classifier for each one of our output
states here for our input this is where
I was saying that it gets a little bit
weird with things that you wouldn't
think of we actually have to introduce
some new tokens into our language so
specifically a start of sequence and an
end of sequence token so the end of
sequence is going to be used down here
when we know that we want to to tell us
that we want to truncate our sentence
that we've got to the end of our
sentence the start of sequence is going
to be used to seed our sentence to say
we want to start a sentence or a decoder
for here it's not as important but it's
it's just as easy to slap those on
anyways it doesn't hurt anything so
these are just like new words in your
vocabulary so you have startup sequence
and then you just make sure that you
seed your your output LST on your
decoder LS TM with a startup sequence so
it knows that this is starting
when we're calculating the loss we want
to take the prediction from each one of
these guys but we want to so the
sequence that we feed in down here
starts with start of sequence and goes
to the end of the sentence but it
doesn't have the end of sequence so we
take the start of sequence but we don't
put the end of sequence on there because
we want it to produce the end of C so we
don't want it to learn to produce an end
of sequence from an end of sequence that
that creates this kind of loop in the in
the training and messes things up so you
want to feed in an input that's shifted
one over from the output that you're
trying to predict so we started with the
start of sequence we want it to predict
the first word then we feed in the first
word we want it to predict the second
word etc and then we feed in the last
word and we want it to learn that at the
last word it needs to produce an end of
sequence and then when we run inference
on the model when we're just feeding in
words we start it with a start of
sequence and then as soon as it gets
this thing can generate words all day as
soon as it gets to an end of sequence
for the first time then we cut it off
and we say that's the translation any
questions on that
yep
so actually the hidden state and the
output are actually the same thing so
the the cell state is something
different and I'm using I'm saying that
I'm pulling out the hidden state here
just because I'm feeding into a new LS
TM and I just want something to occupy
the cell state as well and I didn't find
anything good in the literature but in
the literature they say that they
usually just pull out the hidden state
but yeah but the hidden state if you
look at the if you go back to that LS TM
direct diagram that I have the arrows at
the top that go to the output into the
hidden state are actually that's just
splitting off from one arrow so it's
just that's
why are you then outputting to to one
house is it looking to output to Avenger
yeah that's that's a good point I
haven't seen anything in the literature
with doing that but I think Matt so Matt
Matt works with me it doesn't be in his
[Music]
and you're just dotting you have a and
so and then here's aa flexing that so
essentially you are kind of doing
addicted because where they where they
overlap the most
[Music]
yeah yeah so so the the crux of this
type of this type of architecture is
that you hope that this fixed length the
context vector it's it's a fixed length
vector it's just whatever the shape of
your hidden state was is able to encode
your entire all the information that was
contained in your input sequence so if
we go back to sequential models this is
essentially the contacts reminder right
here we're just taking the last the last
output or the last hidden state and just
feeding that in as our contacts factor
so we're just looking to come up with
some sort of representation and that has
bye-bye how the architecture is put
together that should have information
about every part of the sequence
I mentioned bi-directional LS TM s
that's typically what people will do
like if you look at people that have
more than a 15-inch MacBook Pro and they
can run run more stuff they'll have like
a multi-layer LST em that's
bi-directional so then you're capturing
information going both directions using
multiple layers so you're using and then
that each one of those layers will have
an output vector and then you can just
concatenate all of those so then you
have instead of just like a 50
dimensional vector from one lsdm you
have 150 dimensional vector from three
LST ins and then they're all capturing
different levels of information about
your ear context so that's like if you
go look go to most of the blogs out
there that are talking about this or
research papers that's typically what
they'll do and then there's more
advanced techniques that can that allow
you so we're by doing it like this we're
just throwing away all of this
information we have here like we each
one these things aren't useful there
there's no doubt about the usefulness of
these and there's there's other
approaches called attention mechanisms
that allow the model to learn how much
it should pay attention and include
information from each one of these
output states as well so you basically
hit like a soft max distribution over
each one of the the words in the input
sequence and those are really cool
models
what's a typical dimension for for what
the hidden state oh the context it
depends on if I'm training at my typical
dimension is like 100 100 to 300 if you
look at like Google this will be like a
thousand ninety-six or like like two
thousand or something so though though
use really and I mean you you need to do
that when you're training with a ton of
data like they'll train on like all of
the data that Google has accessible to
them for a month at a time and to like
really produce their produce a good
version of their Google Translate
product so you want that to be able to
contain a lot of a lot of tunable
parameters cuz you're throwing a ton of
data at it where there's some attention
mechanism is implemented in towards
itself or do you have people and other
other repositories that have implemented
oh no there's there's tongue actually it
was hard for me to find any examples of
this so everything now even the default
example on the the PI torch the pipe or
tutorials website says oh yeah there's
this thing encoder decoder thing but
here's attention so they're like it's
that that's kind of like the standard
now this is just like a pretty basic
version that does that does the trick as
well cool any more questions
all right so the last thing that I want
to talk about that with this is teacher
forcing so this example here where I'm
talking about training it and
calculating the loss this is with 100%
teacher forcing and what I mean by
teacher forcing is I'm feeding in the
the known output sequence as the input
regardless of what the last output was
so in practice I don't know what that
output sequence is right but when I'm
training it I do so teacher forcing says
well I'm going to teach the model what
the what the right next output should be
by just telling it feeding that in as my
input for the right next output but most
most implementations of this have what
they call a teacher forcing ratio so
some of the time you're gonna feed in
you're gonna do this teacher forcing
you're gonna feed in the the known label
but other times you're actually going to
just take the the predicted value for
the next thing and feed that in as your
next input and this this helps to from
what I've read this helps to prevent
this helps to prevent your model from
learning sequences of words that fit
together but don't necessarily make a
ton of sense in the context of your of
whatever your problem is so you you
might get a word that like kind of makes
sense like you can see how these words
fit together maybe you can sneak it by
like your dissertation adviser or
something for like half of your PhD
thesis but not the whole thing so cool
so for inference like I was saying
before you would take in your input
sequence convert it to a context vector
and then you don't you have no idea what
that what the expected output is right
that's the thing that you're trying to
figure out so all you can do is just
seed this with a start of sentence
vector and then you take the prediction
for the previous one and keep going
until you hit an end of sequence and
then you just cut it off and then that's
what you return as your actual value
there's no guarantee that you ever know
so you usually in most implementations
of this you'll see some sort of max
cutoff and I actually have that in in
this notebook
yeah yeah yeah I can't speak to whether
or not one's better than the other but I
have seen that as well so a lot of times
what I'll see in they don't just input
the contacts factor but they concatenate
the context vector with the with the
actual input or they'll like stack them
on top of each other and if you think
this is why I like neural nets so much
because you can kind of think of what
that would do right instead of just
saying I want the information from the
the encoded sequence to just be input in
them in the beginning you can say well I
want that to be carried I want to make
sure I want to ensure that I carry that
along for the whole whole length of my
of my actual output sequence generation
so you're just enforcing then that
instead of like the encoded information
is going to be there for the whole time
that it's decoding cool any more
questions so I have we are 10 minutes
over and I have the same exact
walkthrough we have the same exact
walkthrough for the other one but I'm
just gonna breeze through it so I don't
I don't keep y'all too much longer so
have all of my imports here I do the
same exact thing that I did for the
other ones cleaning up the text a bit
and then I'm just gonna slap on the
start of sequence and end of sequence
token and I'm gonna do that before I
calculate my input and output lookups so
I calculate those guys and then here I
just create input sequences and output
sequences so input
so that's just a long it's just a whole
bunch of lists of vectors there of
integers sorry so if we want to create
all the individual components for this
we need an encoding embedding layer and
I'll set the embedding dimension equal
to 100 and then we need an encoder RNN
that's all that we need for the encoder
because we're not going we don't need a
soft max we don't need any of that stuff
we don't need a linear layer because
we're not doing anything with that we
just want to feed out feed in the raw
output of this and then for our decoder
we need a decoding decoder embedding
layer and a decoder RNN and the decoder
input size I'm sorry the decoder hidden
size has to match the match whatever
you're feeding in from the encoder to
the decoder so the context vector this
has to be the same as this if you're
feeding in the the hidden state if
you're gonna concatenate things like if
you have like a multi-layer RNN then
this should be like if you had a two
layer RN and then this would be a
hundred if you were just going to
concatenate those things on top of each
other and then for our decoder because
we're going to be doing actual
classification here we have a linear
layer that's the output the hidden the
hidden layer shape the hidden dimension
of the decoder LS TM and then the output
size and then we apply a soft max to
that and then we have our log softmax to
that and our again our negative like log
likelihood loss so define all of those
guys and then we can just pass this
through and then this I think will be
the the last step so I'll just talk
through this so our input sequence
tensor shape is just a sequence of 16
integers our output sequence shape is 13
so this is we don't have equal sizes for
our sequences and we run our input
sequence through our embedding and then
we get a sequence of 16 100 dimensional
vectors then we pass our oh sorry then I
squeeze that guy why do I have this
I think that I don't have the the shape
right there yes so our encoder output
shape is going to be 16 by 1 by 50 so
this is our batch dimension this is our
sequence length and now we have an
output for each one of those our hidden
shapes for our hidden vector our hidden
state is going to be 1 by 1 by 50 and
our con our cell state is going to be 1
by 1 by 50 so we're gonna pass in this
couple of things into our decoder hidden
state to initialize it our decoder
embedding again 13 by a hundred thirteen
by a hundred we're gonna pass that
through and our LS TM input shape is
going to be twelve by a hundred because
we want to strip off when we're feeding
in doing teacher forcing we want to
strip off the end character because we
want it to predict that end of sequence
character so we're going to start with
the start of sequence but strip off the
end of sequence and then for our output
for that our this is our linear output
shape and then our output target shape
is going to be 12 as well because we're
stripping off that starter silence we
want to match up the start of sequence
with the word after the start of
sequence and then this is just verifying
that that the the softmax is actually
doing a softbox check so if I sum over
all of the 15 thousand dimensional
representation of all of the 15 thousand
words that I could have after I run a
softmax on that I expect that to sum to
one and I expect there to be 12 of those
because I have 12 elements in my
sequence so this is just a sanity check
to make sure that things are working and
then this is briefing encoded as as pi
torch model so the only other thing that
I'll mention here is notice I have an
encoder module I have a decoder module
and then I have a sequence to sequence
model where I initialize that sequence
to sequence model with an already
created encoder and already created
decoder and this this initialization can
even create those things if I passed in
all the input parameters that I wanted
to for that and then I have a forward
for this guy that just calls it walks
through and initializes the hidden
States walks it passes the encoder
passes the the input sequence through
the the encoder grabs the hidden state
of that and calls it the decoder hidden
state and then loops through the the
individual elements of the decoder the
output sequence and based on some sort
of a probability of teacher forcing it
says do I feed in the inputs or the the
actual output sequence or do I feed in
the output from the decoder or the next
one and then I just return the stacked
output of that guy so that gives you all
of your individual integers and yeah
this guy learns really poorly on this
small data set but I can let it run for
a second that defines all of them this
will train it
so notice how I'm just creating a
sequence to sequence model and I'm only
calling that forward on that so it's
really cool how you can just how hi
torch models can just chain on top of
each other so you can just create a
module and then use that just like I've
been using linear layers as as a
component of another model so I stopped
that really quickly and then this is
just the predict method so it actually
predicted a sentence but this didn't end
in an end so this it would have just
gone on for a while so I stopped it so
yeah we are we are officially well over
time so thank you everybody for your for
your time and
[Applause]